it is May 3rd 2023 and you're watching
the code report kids these days are no
longer cheating on their homework like
they used to college cheating platform
Chegg was down 50 yesterday after
revealing that chat GPT is killing its
business a ridiculous 89 of students are
already using Chachi PT and that's bad
news for any kind of tutoring platform
the company is taking a if you can't
beat them join them strategy and signed
up for the open AI API to develop
something called chegmate and that's why
we're working with gpt4 to help students
cheat themselves out of a real education
but you got to break some chegs if you
want to make an omelet and the bodies of
chat GPT are starting to pile up
BuzzFeed and vice media are both going
out of business in part because AI can
now write deep enlightening articles
like 10 reasons JavaScript is homophobic
you've also got language learning apps
like Duolingo afraid right now because
it looks like llms will become Superior
second language teachers making their
products obsolete LegalZoom is also
tanking as we speak because they're in
the direct Kill Zone of AI nobody's
going to be paying to fill out legal
templates when you can tell Chachi BT to
generate one for you for free once the
chat GPT retrieval plugin goes live
every company will be able to hook up
their own data to generate legal
documents on the Fly that's game over
for LegalZoom but the company that
stands to lose the most in the AI race
if it doesn't win is Google alphabet
just had great earnings but if chat gbt
continues to grow at this rate it's
literally the fastest growing app of all
time Google search traffic should go
down that would be bad because search
ads are one of the biggest cash cows of
all time that account for over 50
percent of alphabet's Revenue but Google
doesn't want to lose to Microsoft Google
I O is exactly one week away and it'll
be interesting to see what they have in
store bad news for Google though AI
Pioneer Jeffrey Hinton just quit he's
often called one of the Godfathers of
deep learning and helped Pioneer things
like back propagation and neural
networks that we use today he resigned
because he wants to be able to quote
freely speak about the risks of AI he's
afraid Putin and DeSantis will use it to
win elections or use it to build
hyper-intelligent killing machines his
resignation was a surprise but he made
it clear that Google has acted
responsibly with its AI Endeavors this
guy's pretty smart and if he says AI is
dangerous we might want to listen to him
but I don't think Putin gonna the
Russians just announced their own large
language model last week called gigachat
I know from experience that Russians are
very talented AI researchers and am
somewhat skeptical that they'll pause
their research if the AI turns out to be
a little sexist but getting back to
hyper-intelligent killing machines
palantir just demonstrated some
Innovative new ways to blow people up
with AI the operator uses AIP to
generate three possible courses of
action to Target this enemy equipment
send these three options to my commander
it looks like the job of Lieutenant is
dead but IBM one of the biggest
Employers in Tech just announced that it
will be eliminating 7 800 jobs over the
next five years people seem to forget
that IBM is a big AI player that created
Watson to beat Ken Jennings in Jeopardy
over a decade ago but the jobs going
away are mostly back office rules like
HR and paper pushers that we already
know AI is going to replace what would
you say
you do here
the scary thing is that there's
Consultants just like these guys
teaching dinosaur companies how to
replace humans with AI the vast majority
of this will take place behind closed
doors and you'll never hear about it in
the news Goldman Sachs predicts 300
million jobs could be lost to AI in the
coming years the good news though is
that programming jobs appear to be safe
for the time being and it's reassuring
to know that 60 of workers today are in
occupations that didn't exist in 1940.
AI is likely going to create a bunch of
new jobs like of course the printer and
many others that we haven't even
imagined yet furthermore a new paper
just dropped explaining how all the
scary emergent AI hype is really just a
mirage produced by researchers it's
almost like even the smartest people in
the world don't know what the hell is
going on with AI or maybe they know
exactly what's going on but they just
want to Hype it up and regulate it so
they can control it and make tons of
money from it before the average person
figures out how to train their own
state-of-the-art models that can prove
once and for all that we're not on a
spinning ball because that's what this
is all about this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one